[Music]
if I detailed all of their credentials
we'd be up here for most of the time we
have allotted so we'll just have kind of
a brief introduction of everyone so
Jonathan Roberts is dot-com formerly
known as about calm
they have several properties that are
kind of distributed all over that they
maintain Claudia Pollak is the chief
scientist at distillery an adjunct at
NYU Stern School of Business and invite
an advisor at data Society Research
Institute Chandra Hill is a senior
researcher at Microsoft Chris Wiggins an
associate professor at Columbia founder
of hakkon why the chief data scientists
at the New York Times and highly I would
sue is the chief data scientist at
Mashable so I'm just going to go grab
this
so in your experience where have been
the largest disconnects between the the
hype around machine learning and the
value it's actually delivered because I
think there's a lot of interesting
discussion that we could have on that
point kind of around this particular
well that's one of those topics where
you can go into kind of many different
directions and I mean the hype is kind
of to start there we've been doing
machine learning for I don't know 25
whatever years so that the understanding
of what the tools that can do to solve
problems has been around for a long time
and I think the problems to make it
happen haven't really changed at all the
only good news is that I see a lot more
kind of interest from the management
level hey shouldn't we be doing
something with data where didn't used to
be and that was one of the bigger
problems we had in the earlier days that
it wasn't necessarily easy to push a
solution that management didn't
necessarily understand very well and to
help them start making decisions based
on that that problem is still there I
think now we have the opposite we should
be doing something with AI somebody go
out there and do something with AI and
so all of a sudden now people build all
kind of sentiment classifiers or
classifiers for cats and dogs and I
don't know what and the question then is
while what is this actually good for so
so now I think the problem has almost
become the opposite that we're solving a
lot of fun problem and the geeks have a
great time with it but then the
translation back to well how could this
even be remotely integrated in a
business decision process that
ultimately benefits somebody beyond the
pretty pictures and the fun geek time so
that would be my very kind of high-level
observation where things are
disconnected
very interesting Chris you have some
ideas around this as well well as
somebody who has data science in my job
title I would say there's no hype about
data science it's really that good
you should you should hire all of us
know so that the hype I don't think is
that they designs is somehow less
powerful than people predict but rather
hear people characterize but rather that
people are constantly optimizing the
wrong thing so I'll follow up on what
Claudia said which is not only do people
spend a lot of time getting really good
quantitative performance on the wrong
metric but there's also a real lack of
careful thought about product decisions
and what is a good idea for an AI goal
you know it's it's not clear that the
right AI goal is to maximize clicks or
maximize engagement for example in the
context of product decisions nor the
mission of a company so I don't know
that there's a lot of I I don't know
that I'd characterize machine learning
as having too much hype Claudia is right
the machine learning has been around for
a long time the term machine learning
has been around since in 1959 but rather
I think there's a lot of displaced
attention to AI is going to create the
Terminator which i think is as those of
us who know how hard it is to make
things work we're not so worried about
the Terminator taking over yet but I
think there's a lot of plenty of real
and present problems created by AI used
to optimize really the wrong thing
either because it's wrong for your
business or because it's contrary to the
to the mission of the company there is
an interesting question so how do you
keep an eye toward generating value with
data science and optimizing the right
metrics executing the right projects and
how do you kind of balance that with
going deep into understanding the system
that you're working in doing good
science around the content performance
for example quantifying your content and
and so on like that yeah I think to
Chris's point I was like Claudia's the
the key here is actually going after the
right thing and machine learning will
really tell you what the right thing is
that's just a science problem actually
to begin with to try and give people
insights into what's going on why it's
going on what kind of features could
possibly be important and then what you
actually make a decision about to the
business I think one of the big risks
around the
the popularity of machine learning as a
concept and there's a kind of dinner
table to discussion among CEOs right now
is that machine learning is now data
science and therefore all day to
sciences machine learning and so they've
kind of forgotten that a large part of
this is just science applying thought to
a problem and figuring out what the
answer could be and when you have
machine learning with no Direction
applied to it then you end up in these
issues of optimizing to their own KPI or
optimizing blindly and it kind of going
off in a wrong direction and so it's
something that we actually try very hard
to do which is segments that two types
of problem quite cleanly for the
management so they know what types of
problems fall into which bucket and so
they're not trying to use a big shiny
hammer where everything is now a machine
learning nail sure so and just as a bit
of background so I spent a lot of time
as a faculty member
kind of researching things that I was
personally interested in and they
thought the research community was
interested in I'm now at Microsoft in a
company in what becomes increasingly
important is to work on projects that
product groups and managers actually
care about and so you cannot kind of sit
in your own bubble and just kind of
dream up problems because the data
exists because the reality is that data
exists right we have where we're
overwhelmed with data but it's really
important to you know really be in tight
communications with leadership and
making sure that you understand one what
their pain points are to what their
objectives are and three kind of what
their timeline is because another thing
that happens with data scientists often
is that you kind of have a six-month
time horizon but people making decisions
have a two-month time horizon right and
so all of those things I think become
really important and making sure you're
not kind of operating in a bubble and
working with whoever leadership is who's
making decisions and knowing what their
pain points are so that's that's
interesting that the time horizons can
be so different so so that's that's
another interesting kind of
direction that we could go how do you
how do you make sure that the time
horizon to do good science aligns with
the time horizon for business
deliverables because it's a very it's a
fast changing environment is there
something like agile for data science
data science for example so I'd like to
hear you kind of your opinions I've
always been really skeptical of agile
for data science primarily because I
really am a very strong believer in data
science as a science and I I think
there's something about the the the
process of inquiry that that runs a
little bit countered but I think to keep
data science quite honest and the rest
of the panelists to be really anchored
in in in productizing data science tends
to as you might imagine shorten
shortened time scale so you know I in at
Mashable we find that we have projects
that are so intimately bound to a
definite product that sort of two months
time horizon is something that we keep
strictly to and then we have a set of
projects that are much more sort of
foundational Rd Rd base and we the the
former buys room for the latter we find
success with the former run on the
interplay of time timer Iceland and
science the one thing I'd love to
somehow teach people coming out of their
science programs to be kind of know
earlier is it's really great to have a
quick and dirty no it's like almost in
null hypothesis is like you have to
build something that works half way
reliably in two weeks can we please not
start with deep learning but hey maybe
you have some other quick idea of what
you can actually and you also have a
baseline for what you have to beat and
how much this additional complexity that
you put into not just building this
thing the first time but because then
some engineering team has to maintain it
right so having a fast solution that is
robust but simple and then the science
being
the hypothesis how much better can you
get reliably on top of that and that you
can take a little bit more time for and
then it's a business decision is it
worth it but it doesn't have to be fancy
right out of them that they get go it
can actually be quite simple and that's
really a great product and still part of
science because you need to have a
baseline Kristen
sure if you don't mind me jumping in
because I know highly would like to say
something good I believe that words have
meaning so agile
it's worse than Big Data now I have no
idea what somebody know I have no idea
what somebody means with a very
nice-looking website with the 12
principles and yes
so I'm also quite Orthodox when it comes
to things like when there's a clear atom
ology for a thing let's go and see what
those people we're talking about so
let's go look at that website it had
four principles for what it means to be
agile and those principles I don't think
anybody would argue with including like
interaction with the person you're
working with like prioritizing
interactions with people rather than
JIRA tickets totally down with that if
that's what you mean by agile if you
mean JIRA tickets and like weekly scrums
I'm not so sure because god knows what
sort of cult I'm buying myself into okay
I've already had two coffees I'm gonna
go off in a rant the question he asked
was is there such a thing as agile for
data scientists so our group at the New
York Times we're fortunate to have
people who really try to build data
product so for that I'm totally into
edge I'll when somebody says oh we might
have this interesting idea maybe we
should sprinkle some data science on it
I'm like no if you're willing to have
weekly interactions with us and and make
sure that we're building the right thing
and make sure that you stay engaged then
I'm willing to work with you because I
believe in interactions with people in
regular iteration so actually I'm
totally down with having agility and
data science if I get to define what
agile means and I actually like that
website right it's got four principles
that I think are pretty and arguable
sorry highly
I was actually just going to follow up
and ask Claudia whether in your
experience the the kind of null result
of the civil bass line was primarily as
set up by the data science team or it's
sort of determined what the the minimal
version would be is a primarily a
business my experience is that the
question is really how data science
savvy your product or lead of product is
and whether they have that judgment call
in our case they came from engineering
and they tended to over engineer the ETL
process so I think that was actually the
more senior the most senior data
scientist who had tried to solve a
problem like this and stumbled into all
of the problems when you try to build
the de big like right like perfect
solution so it's almost like yeah the
oldest data scientists in the room who
comes up with the simple solution to the
problem typically because they have
experienced this product before and they
have been through numerous rounds of
trying to build something agile or not
and so that's kind of the experience
they bring to the table yeah when you do
the simple thing you usually find out
your preconceived idea of what you were
going to find is completely wrong and if
you go and build the over engineered
solution you mean every spot that you
were wrong because very hard to figure
out what's going on inside those systems
and then the other piece that we can't
touch on a little bit but we haven't
really got into is their design seems
don't live in a vacuum right they live
tightly coupled to a taper operations or
a data engineering group and agile helps
that collaboration a lot right or some
agile structures and like structured
communication that means that you're not
just walking in and saying oh I need
this like half a terabyte of data and I
need it to be this responsive and I need
it by tomorrow because my deadline is
tomorrow right and then you're ahead of
day to operation should take you back if
you do that to them and and so having
that cadence serve of regular check-ins
across teams and when you're so tightly
coupled into those areas
we found to be hugely successful when we
got it to work and then terrible when it
wasn't working the country so I want to
shift a little bit content distribution
has changed a lot over the years so I
wanted to kind of talk about a little
bit about what that kind of cross
platform media environment looks like in
particular the interaction between
Facebook Twitter web sites TV media as
well Shondra would you like to talk a
little bit about kind of the TV and
media interplay a little bit sure so I
spend pretty much 80% of my time looking
at how people respond to television
content online so looking at out
effectiveness and also how people search
intent for example changes over the
course of the day when TV shows are on
so the data that we have now so data
that are and I'm sitting in databases
and companies things like clicks on the
web Facebook you know tweets enable us
to measure audiences to see how
different coordinated efforts across
channels play out with respect to people
buying things and clicking on the web so
all that said I think it's a really
exciting time to both you know kind of
revisit how we measure audiences because
how people consume media has changed but
then at the same time how people consume
media is constantly changing so the you
know kind of the bar for getting it
right
keeps changing I will say though that
I'm extremely optimistic about the
future and don't you know am a data
scientist at heart and I try and I am a
privacy friendly data scientist but
what's exciting is that we are able to
connect the dots across these different
companies through different cooking
solutions and now for TV in particular
there's something that's called
addressable television not sure if
you've heard of it but basically
advertisers are going to be able to
target individual level households and
so once that becomes mainstream then one
who is an advertiser or even at
the show producer can think about
coordinating efforts at the individual
household level so we don't have to
guess anymore about the effectiveness of
particular channels because we'll
actually be able to experiment across
them because we know exactly who's
seeing what piece of content on what
device on what website so I think the
future is extremely bright from the
perspective of you know doing this
individual targeting and we can get into
I think later some of the privacy
implications of that yeah very cool so
you're saying that online and kind of TV
across its re interactions provide a lot
more measurement opportunities so we can
actually go from before where we had TV
audiences we couldn't interact with
directly now we can interact with them
online measure ad effectiveness that way
yeah I mean I could just give you like a
couple make it concrete right so some
things that we found in the research
that we do is people are responding more
on mobile phone to TV content right and
so that's kind of obvious in hindsight
you're not bringing your desktop you
know to sit in front of the television
but until we had data where we could see
what types of devices people are
searching from or clicking from we
wouldn't be able to measure those
heterogeneous kind of treatment effects
right some other examples are we look at
whether sales are impacted when people
are watching television and so what we
find is for really complex products so
things that you have to think about
things think of like financial
instruments like getting a loan or
something like that at one extreme and
then you know buying a beauty product or
something at the other extreme where you
kind of know what you want a lipstick
color or whatever those products are not
impacted in the same way and so again
because of the data that we have we can
be able we can begin to ask these
questions about like what the impact of
something happening on one channel is on
you know somebody's behavior on other
digital channels Claudia you work in
kind
audience targeting in this kind of
distributed median yes so I joined an
attic company about almost eight years
ago precisely for the fact that it's
mean it's like man the best playground
for data science ever in terms of the
data you have and the experimentation
you can do I have grown a little cynical
over the years being in this business it
comes back to what Chris also mentioned
on we're at large optimizing for the
wrong things now I can look at this I
mean there's a silver lining to right
you can look at this as being the
modern-day Robin Hood transferring money
from the rich brands to the poor
publishers and nobody gets hurt in the
process because we haven't figured out
really how to manipulate people into
buying stuff they don't need but the the
issue remains that it all depends on the
measurements in place and the incentives
that people have to act so the
measurements right now aren't really ad
giving me any kind of credit for
changing people's behavior so right now
I'm not being paid if I can manage to
change your probability of buying
something I'm just being paid for
predicting that you would buy the stuff
whether I show you an ad or not and so
there are a lot of artifacts that come
out of this scenario of misaligned
incentives in combination with really
really good machine learning I'm not
sure that's still the case but it used
to be when you watched a series on Hulu
you would get the same spot for dog food
20 times in a row remember this now who
in their mind could think that this is a
good idea I mean seriously who could
possibly believe this is a good idea
eventually you would get this little box
it's just a tour elephant to you and
even if you had three dogs running
around hungry starving in your place you
would say no and the vain hope to get
anything else right now again why is
that it's because they were measuring
video as in audience and guess what I am
the same middle-aged soccer mom every
single time you show me this ad so I
mean I'm counting as a good
single time you show it to me and so
these are the kind of tensions that come
when you have the wrong things to
optimize for with good or bad data
either way and so as much as I agree
with Chandra that the data is incredible
and all the things we can do the
industry itself isn't in a great state
of really taking advantage of it the
right way gosh there's so much to work
with it I I will agree with Chandra that
the future is bright for a hyper
targeted advertising I will not agree
with Claudia that there's a plausible
Robin Hood model given that 90 cents and
every digital dollar is not going to the
port publishers it's going to to
platform companies and those platform
companies are doing a good job with
hyper targeted advertising and I will
agree with Claudia that in part there's
a there's a prediction prescription
problem with the way people spend money
that like we all have been haven't we as
a species have gotten pretty good at
predicting what's gonna happen in the
absence of treatment from observational
data which is sort of the the supervised
learning problem it's much harder to
explain to people that that's not
actually what they want what they
actually want to know is and it was it
was implicit in something Shawna just
said she almost said conditional average
treatment effect she's she's getting at
the fact that there is a whole
literature in called the well you know
right causal inference right so like
we're just getting to the point that
most marketers that like the people who
are actually like feeding the beast with
their money are understanding the
quantitative aspects of predicting
things it's going to take a while before
we get people to understand that
predicting what's gonna happen in the
absence of treatment is different than
prescribing what is the optimal
treatment for example you don't need to
see that dog food so there's a lot to
think about there and and to get back to
your original question Adam you know if
you think about like the flow of
information on different platforms
Twitter Facebook what have you I don't
think you can really think about that
without thinking about money because it
is the business model of the attention
driven economy that's completely upended
the way our relationship with the as a
species our relationship with
information and the last 15 years
it's just changed everything and that's
really what's driving product decisions
at Twitter product decisions at
Facebook's targeting decision decisions
at those two companies and oriental
throwing Google they're just since it's
Google and Facebook that are eating the
lion's share of all digital advertising
the business model of these platform
companies is really something you need
to think about centrally rather than
enumerated a long list of you know
snapchat de jour or whatever the next
years instant face will be it's really
the choice of business model that's
driving these product decisions and
changing the way we all interact with
information slightly different answer to
your question about the way that the the
distribution of the the variety of
distributional outlets for content has
changed the business I think one one of
the things that's really intriguing for
for us when we're making content
recommendations is that you know for a
publisher who has to service growing
audiences on Facebook Twitter snapchat
you know email what's up there's you
typically have finite editorial
resources and so in order to generate
content that lives on all those
platforms you have to think very very
hard about how to make that content
efficiently and manipulable to live on
those different platforms and so if
you're attempting to make a
recommendation for the type of content
to focus on that's that that vastly
complicates the kind of I think content
science you have to do in order to make
a recommendation that's a big change
from the sort of scenario where you you
said you have one article or perhaps one
video that that lives statically in
these different places
Johnathan's the problems even more
complex for you because you have there's
so many different properties right well
okay so we have about six different big
problems the moment there used to be a
thousand different subdomains that had
existed since a ban in 1996 where you
giggles so we don't wear long baseline
data on the internet I think we're one
of the few companies actually has that
um and my answers are gonna be
completely opposite to everything else
that's just been said up here because
for us when you look at that data you
find that the questions people ask don't
change like the country hasn't actually
changed what it cares about or what it
needs to know or what information is
looking for the way in which those
questions are asked has changed as if
you look at all the health concerns that
people have around all the different
health topics you look at the percentage
distribution between each of those
topics over time it's remarkably stable
right year on year month on month week
on week and so you can actually predict
what people are gonna care about
tomorrow right and you can't just say
today how is today different from a
normal average day and you find that
actually generally there are only like
large world events that change what
people actually care about for the kind
of content we provide right I think
that's the key difference here because
as highly attuned and driving it's like
putting the right content in front of
somebody and what they read a particular
point in time is a Content
recommendation problem can you allow
targeting sorry yes so we tend to answer
problems that you need a solution right
so from how do I pay my deck to how do
you roast a chicken to what do I do if I
have sort there psoriatic arthritis to
where should I go to eat the best food
in Memphis like these questions where
you actually have something that you are
challenged with that you need to have to
do right and people don't generally go
on Facebook to do investigative research
into the psoriatic arthritis right so
it's it's a very different mindset as to
what you're trying to bury you shouldn't
it's a terrible idea and so it's a very
different mindset you're doing with that
point in time we actually tried a bunch
of different ways in which we put
content in front of people we try kind
of click based viral left based
recommendations and they just didn't
work for us at all I people don't care
about like the shiniest carburetor on
our cars like they want to know how to
fix the problem they've got with their
car and and that's also true for
engagement with advertising for us and
so actually in that particular case the
mindset you're in is something that you
have very little data on right you can
have the cookie history these people all
the way back and you still can have no
idea what happened in the real world
five minutes ago that caused them to
have this prop
but you can see everybody else who's had
that same real-world problem that's
taking them to that point so actually
knowing who they are right now is far
more important for us to knowing who
they were in the last like three to six
months and building up like full user
tracking over that time period actually
was far more successful I want to go
back to something Chris mentioned a
minute ago about the the kind of
statistical causal distinction and and
and whether that's incentivized to
measure it properly
sorry to measure affects causal effects
properly rather than statistical effects
and to use causal effects rather than
statistical effects does anyone want to
kind of give a basic description of the
the problem and kind of explain what
what you think the the status of it is
currently I'll just say that it's old I
mean so are a fish yourself still are a
Fisher you know the Fisher from whom we
derive a lot of our statistics from 100
years ago spent the better part of his
letter career as a consultant for the
tobacco industry trying to convince
people that's not that smoking causes
cancer but that cancer cause smoking so
when you just observe people doing what
they do it's very difficult to to figure
out causality as I like to say and so we
do this all that we can do this all the
time now has data scientists we can we
can watch many attributes of people we
can see what they do just observing what
happens and then we can figure out well
these are the behaviors that are
correlated with the thing that you want
them to do or you want them not to do
but correlation is not causation
although causation does cause
correlation which is why there which is
why they're correlated so so it's a
long-standing problem as far as whether
or not it will change again the the main
source of information I'm sorry the main
source of money and fuel for most of
this is marketing so if marketers are
interested in rigorous attribution then
they will be interested in causal impact
models so once we get to the point that
we have a bunch of PhDs and causality
who are making marketing decisions maybe
we'll get there until then good times
good times good times for the
advertising model because marketing
people are very rarely quantitatively
rigorous about attribution and there's
strong positive bias is rayon the
effects
measure from from observational data as
cloudy was illustrating so I wouldn't
quite go as far as to say in my opinion
there's like a bipolar attitude towards
causality they are the small companies
whose survival depends on them actually
making it in the market they care an
awful lot about causality they're the
big brands who have been doing this for
the last hundred years and there's
status quo and stuff has always been
done this way and they will certainly
have some lip service to causality and
they will hire Nielsen to measure
causality and so on but it remains on
kind of that very flat top line don't
scratch too deep in the surface where
even the official players in the
measurement market I would say are
constantly incentivized to overstate the
causal impact over the correlation and
I've observed that every time we're
being measured I promise you I didn't
have that impact I mean I love it but I
promise I didn't do that well because
they continued to mistake very very good
targeting for causality and it has
become an issue in the sense that it's a
data disparity problem I have much
better data therefore I can predict the
organic propensity you can't measure it
you can doall propensity measuring you
like all day long if your data isn't as
good as mine your estimates of the
propensity aren't as good and everything
I do will look causal so even if they
are trying I mean even if they were to
try the data disparity puts them into a
really problematic position and that
means that only Facebook can measure
Facebook's impact now that's a problem
too right so now you have an huge
incentive problem so I think it's not
for the lack of one thing I think there
are other issues at play as well all of
these platforms are monotonically are
monetarily incentivized to overstate
their data Facebook every now and every
now and then I think a year ago they're
like whoops we've actually been giving
you by a factor of two inflated all of
your video metrics last week Twitter
said we've been estimating
overestimating by two or three percent
the MA use for the last year so okay but
but all but if there's there's not a lot
of rigor and and beginning again there's
so much money being made in the
advertised
model it's it's not real clear that
people are monetized incentivized to do
this accurately sorry Sean do you work
and we don't have a lot of time left so
I wanted to get Chandra's comment and
then take some questions from the
audience so I'll just be really quick I
was just gonna say that I am pretty
encouraged by the fact that that things
will change I mean they're gonna change
slowly there's obviously like a big
agency problem in instead of advertising
where the spend is happening but what is
happening is that there are a lot of
analytics solutions that are being put
in front of the actual advertisers and
so they can then go to ad agencies in
question their their strategies in a way
that they couldn't before and what I'm
seeing is ad agencies are losing
contracts left and right because they
can't really defend in a rigorous way
the choices that they've made so I'm
encouraged by that like that people will
have to start paying attention to
causality and really being specific
about how they're they're setting things
up one or two questions from the
audience
sure so as a classic sre DevOps guy
whatever you want to call it it's funny
to me when you guys say that you want
things to be you don't like that things
are agile but also people are focusing
on the wrong things and looking at the
wrong KPIs and the problem is that at
least with my experience is that you
need the agile process you need quick
iteration loops and you need to have
open communication which agile allows
you to do so that you can recognize the
correct KPIs and you need to create
those MVPs otherwise you're gonna just
be in that ivory tower of science
mindset all the time right so how do you
actually gain value out of what you what
you're trying to do without kind of
using a more structured organizational
approach who said they didn't like agile
yep I I expressed I think the largest
amount of skepticism I didn't however
express skepticism about the idea that
you need a closed communicative
iterative process to steer away from the
the worst excesses of the ivory tower
scenario I do however think you do
need the ivory tower scenario two to do
the science part of data science which
is particularly important for the type
of types of problems that we certainly
encounter in media which are are are
oftentimes deep in of this sort of
causal nature where you you have to do
some novel research in order to make
make make progress I think that we spend
a lot of time I've been in that tech for
more than a decade we spend a lot of
time collecting lots of data and putting
it in various places and kind of
forgetting that it's data about
individuals and we're finding that we're
in an environment now where there are
more and more people who are interested
in taking this data and using it to
influence us for their own agendas not
for marketing per se but for less
socially responsible reasons what does
one of the people on the panel think
about the threat that this big pile of
data we've collected poses to our
society I think we're not raising young
data scientists with a background in
ethics enough and I think that just like
any other profession that has impact as
data science continues to have more and
more impact you'll see a small subset of
faculty injecting ethics into their
education I I agree that we're not
particularly good but I also think that
even if a new minted data scientist was
a big ethical position goes into the
real world and it's told what to do I'm
not sure how much of a dent it's going
to make so I think it's important to
have and keep an eye out for this I
think it becomes a data literacy problem
for all of us as we interact with these
systems that provide us information and
news our ability to understand how they
got there and how much trust you can or
cannot put into those and not intrude
stru ly a data problem I think some of
the influencing activity is around fake
news and politics we would have with or
with our beta data about people being
stored it's just it becomes an artifact
not I mean the histories of the
real-time so we have a society haven't
really learned how to deal with systems
that can predict what we like to see
very well so we need to learn how to
interact with their to make it a little
bit harder on ourselves and sometimes
read something B you probably don't want
to read and again and this is it's if
you looked at newspaper stands in the
70s of the 80s there was a lot of stuff
on the front of those papers that were
fake right it's just now we have the
ability for those things to go viral and
be put in front of a very large number
of people very fast and that gets too
thick and the mr. cute incentives of
like Facebook has a good incentive to
give people like a direct intravenous
injection of sugar that they want to
read even though they kind of believe is
probably not right because that's great
for Facebook's business model and it
keeps people very engaged right and a
lack of understanding of exactly what
extra implications that extraordinarily
powerful viral engine has inside that
system and puts us things really where
we are now I just want to add two things
so first I think with any technology you
kind of have to question what are the
sort of positive aspects of it and what
are the negative aspects of it and you
know we're collecting this data and
using it for a lot of really positive
things whether you look at sort of
applications in healthcare education or
otherwise so you know it's not like we
want to just stop collecting data right
because there are these positive aspects
but then the second thing I just wanted
to add is there's a burgeoning research
community that's looking at fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
because of the fact that we're
collecting so much data on people and so
there's a fee it's you know that the for
us is fate at Microsoft and there's a
really active community and then there's
a conference called fat ml which is
fairness accountability and transparency
and machine learning and so you're not
alone in questioning this but the nice
thing is that they're really smart
people now kind of thinking about these
issues
and I look forward to kind of learning
from what you know they come up with
it's an incredibly important topic I
wish we had all day to go into it but
we'll have to in the panel here and
let's all think our panelists
[Applause]
[Music]